from an alternate zerg twist to a monkey
version of socks and even more pizza
planet easter eggs pixar's light year
was originally a very different movie
yupi kaye movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm revealing everything
pixar deleted from light year spoilers
ahead of course so take care the big
twist in light year comes when the
identity of zerg is revealed and it
turns out he's an older version of buzz
from an alternate timeline when buzz
finally achieved 100 hyper speed the
event split the timeline notice these
two bursts of energy which occur at that
very moment the second buzz travelled
centuries into the future and discovered
a ship with advanced alien technology an
enormous mecca robot suit and cyclops
robots who mispronounced his name as
zerg but when older buzz aka zerg opens
his robot suit main timeline buzz
initially mistakes him for his father
because of his similar but aged features
originally pixar planned for the twist
in light year to be that zerg had indeed
been buzz's father all along which would
have matched the same reveal in toy
story 2. you killed my father
i
am your father
director angus mclean explained that
during the movie's development they
spent a lot of time laying the
groundwork and hints to the big reveal
that zerg was in fact buzz's dad but
when the payoff came it felt incredibly
unsatisfying because it was too obvious
from all the clues that have been teased
for at least the first hour of the movie
on top of that there was the fact that
everyone who'd ever seen toy story 2
knew this twist about zerg had already
been played as a star wars joke in that
movie so in the end mclean decided it
would be more interesting if the twist
was that zerg was a version of buzz
himself but one that went on a different
darker path so buzz turns out to
basically be his own worst enemy the
director said he was inspired by indiana
jones and the raiders of the lost ark
where the french archaeologist who works
with the nazis tells indy that he's just
a slightly different version of him i am
a shadowy reflection of you take only a
nudge to make you like me i can see that
having zerger's buzz's father would have
been way too predictable and the disney
animated series buzz lightyear of star
command already spoofed the toy story 2
revelation in favor of making zerg a
straight up villain unrelated to buzz
there's something you must know buzz i
am your father what
psych made you look
so light years filmmakers likely felt
they wanted to do something different to
that particular take in the new movie as
well
a firm fan favorite in the new movie is
the hilarious robotic cat socks sucks
you're inhibiting my visual oh sorry is
this better negative okay how about this
but originally the filmmakers had
planned to have a monkey as buzz's cute
animal sidekick instead the idea for a
monkey came from how nasa and other
space agencies have sent monkeys and
other primates into space as part of
research into space travel the
filmmakers planned on having a type of
helper monkey who would assist buzz on
his missions in the end though they
found a robotic cat was funnier than a
monkey sucks how long were we gone
people people people people people so
they ended up with socks and his amusing
animatronic style of movement and
commentary buzz that was utterly
terrifying and i regret having joined
you the pizza planet trekking franchise
which first appeared in toy story has
made an appearance in almost every pixar
movie so far lightyear is no exception
and a pizza delivery vehicle makes it
tricky to spot cameo in the scene where
buzz and socks are fleeing the star
command police as they drive down the
highway you can see the iconic pizza
planet rocket on top of a truck parked
up and a guy delivering some pizzas but
originally as we can see from this
unused concept art there were also plans
to show scenes with pizza planet stores
and locations on the new planet giving
us more of an insight into the layout of
this new world and how people were
living there and apparently in another
deleted scene buzz would have gone
grocery shopping after he ran out of his
pre-assigned meals there was going to be
a joke where buzz asked for a packet of
dinner like the meal boxes he was used
to eating thus after his many years away
food has changed and he ended up being
sold something called pobbles which
mclean described as spiky space food the
concept art also has some references to
the green aliens who buzz first met at
pizza planet in toy story who's in
charge here
some fans have been disappointed they
didn't make an appearance in light year
especially as some of the little green
men worked for star command in the
animated series however mclean has
explained that he didn't think it made
sense for them to appear in light year a
movie that andy saw before the events of
toy story as the aliens don't know who
buzz is when he pops up in their claw
machine and toy story it fits that they
shouldn't have met him previously in the
new prequel movie maclean has confirmed
though that there is an easter egg to
squeeze toy aliens in the first
mid-credits scene where you can see a
little statue of one of the green men on
commander burnside shelf and if you're a
fan of the hilarious little green men or
you're enjoying this video so far do
leave a thumbs up i really appreciate it
when zerg confronts buzz for the first
time and corners him buzz is saved when
the junior's at patrol blasts the
villain to the floor as zerg recovers he
uses his arm controls to call on a team
of cyclops to help him trap buzz the
original storyboard for this sequence
reveals a hilarious little deleted
moment where the zerg bots can be seen
chilling out in a lounge on the ship
playing cards and pool together just
before zerg's command activates them
also cut from the final movie was a
scene involving a killer robot hound
that zerg had sent to hunt buzz in the
future in this deleted rainy action
sequence which has shades of blade
runner buzz would have had a special
briefcase with a weapon though it
completely failed to stop the canine
antagonist and buzz ended up getting
caught by the robot dog
lightyear also made some significant
changes to zerg's design compared to the
toy story movies this serg is more robot
like influenced by anime and mecca and
his huge size was intended to make him
incredibly intimidating this more
robotic look also meant pixar ditched
the cape zerg wore in toy story 2.
knuckles losing zerg's colorful cape
however meant this version of the
villain was heavy on purple and the art
of lightyear book reveals some of zerg's
early designs which included a lot of
red and other colours these were
discarded eventually and instead red
accents were given to zerg via decals
pinstripes and labels zerg's horns were
also reduced in size to appear less
devil-like and this zerg also got an
enormous extendable hand akin to a claw
possibly a nod to the little green men
from toy story
the art of light-year book also reveals
some interesting alternate designs for
commander burnside where he had a bionic
arm which implies there's an interesting
backstory for burnside that we didn't
get to see curiously enough there was
also another character with a bionic arm
who ended up cut from the film
as well as scrapping a storyline which
showed how buzz became a space ranger in
the first place and a sequence which
featured him ending up in a star command
brig over rivalry and insults the art of
lightyear book also reveals a lot of
deleted characters that never made it
into the final movie there were some
miyazaki inspired helper machines called
miner bots that would have presumably
appeared when buzz and the zap patrol
went to the mining plant on the dark
side of the planet there are also all of
these unused characters which the
concept art book reveals as being out of
picture and if you'd like to get a copy
of the art of light year with all these
cool designs and a lot more concept art
including the original designs for buzz
lightyear before toy story when he was
called luna larry you can tap here to
get the book with free worldwide
shipping i'll also add a link in the
video description below
so movie lovers what do you think of the
big zerg twist in light year and is
there anything you wish had been in the
final movie let me know in the comments
next tap here to discover more pixel
deleted scenes like the crazy alternate
ending of turning red and be sure to
like subscribe and tap the bell so you
don't miss out on my next pixar video
thanks for enjoying light year with me
and hope you have a marvelous movie
loving week yapikai movie lovers